I watched the Mad King die I remembered
him laughing at your father burned
itself like justice so where you tell
yourself at night your servants of
Justice that you were avenging my father
and you shove your sword in Aerys
Targaryen is back tell me if I stabbed
the Mad King in the belly instead of the
back would you mind me more
he served him well and certainly was
safe
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones today let's talk
about our old friend our favorite King
Slayer sir Jaime Lannister I want to
discuss the very toxic relationship that
I think he's about to be in with his
sister the Queen Cersei Lannister and
one of their new alliances this season
it's no secret that Jaime and Cersei are
running very low on friends and
alliances at this stage of the game
and now the Daenerys Targaryen is
showing up to Westeros with a large army
and large dragons they're going to need
to find someone else who can back them
when it comes time to fight over who is
going to rule the Seven Kingdoms
Daenerys Targaryen feels that she was
born to rule the Seven Kingdoms but
Cersei Lannister is currently sitting on
the Iron Throne and Cersei has no plans
on giving that up which will eventually
lead to Daenerys ripping it from her
cold dead hands but Cersei will not go
down without a fight and there is a new
man that's about to enter her life
that's going to offer her everything
that she thinks she needs to help her
keep her position intact and that man is
going to be your own Greyjoy everyone
knows that you're on Greyjoy is in the
process of building his thousand ships
so that he can hunt down his niece and
nephew who just ran off with his best
ships in order to form their own
alliance with Daenerys Targaryen so now
you're on needs a new alliance as well
and since you're on already had his own
plans of conquering the Seven Kingdoms
who better then to strike a deal with
then the person that's already sitting
on the Iron Throne
since Daenerys is now out of the
question we've already seen a ton of
evidence in both trailers to know what
you're on is going to be doing next
season at the beginning of season seven
Euron is going to
taxi on and yarra how did see and he's
going to deliver a devastating blow that
will [ __ ] Daenerys his Greyjoy and
Martell alliances after that urine will
be heading straight to King's Landing
with his brand-new fleet and I must say
his new fleet does look pretty badass it
doesn't look like he took that much
damage during the attack his ship
silence doesn't appear to have a scratch
on it but you're honest highly
experienced on the sea so this is kind
of expected when your own gets to King's
Landing he's going to greet with Cersei
and Jaime Lannister and he's going to
tell Cersei everything that she wants to
hear
urine might be psychotic but he's also
very charismatic and cunning too so he's
going to persuade Cersei into teaming up
with him but on the other hand Cersei
does need to help not only does veneris
have the bigger army but Cersei and the
crown are also in a large amount of debt
right now they are still in debt from
when Robert Baratheon was the king and
the Lannister gold mines are drying up
so I think Cersei will take whatever it
is that you're on is offering but I
don't think Jamie is going to love this
new alliance Jaime already doesn't like
the Greyjoy's as it is we've met before
you know ugly strange I've forgotten the
seeds you find before it side by side
one afternoon
let's go you got your scar i one of the
Greyjoy's nearly took my eye this you
sons of [ __ ] they like the blood [ __ ]
they start liking it again I was a
proper battle remember fellas Amir
charging through the bridge with his
burning sword I'll remember that till
the day I die I saw the youngest of the
Greyjoy lads at Winterfell
just like seeing a shark and a
mountaintop Theon
he's a good lot attacked it when you're
on shows up and starts trying to seduce
Cersei this is going to become a big
problem I think this will become one of
those toxic and deadly love triangles
Jaime may not love Cersei like he once
did but I don't think he's going to
allow another man to take his spot
you already know you're on is going to
offer Cersei his big [ __ ] and what do
you think Jamie is going to do about
that in my opinion once you're on
arrives in King's Landing we're going to
see Cersei go into a downward spiral of
even more mad
than we've already seen before you're on
Greyjoy as a psychopath he murders his
own family members he molested his
brother he rapes women he forces people
to eat human flesh and to top it all off
he had the tongues ripped out of the men
who crew his ship when he teams up with
Cersei I can see both of them taking a
very dark turn together
I think Euron's going to be an absolute
savage this season and now that Cersei
has lost all of her children which were
the last people she truly loved she's
going to go right along for the ride
with your own but his men and ships are
not going to be enough to defend an
all-out attack from Daenerys which is
going to leave Cersei and your on with
no choice but to fight as dirty as you
can think of and say what you want about
Jaime but I don't see him standing by
while this [ __ ] goes on if Theon doesn't
end up killing your on somehow then I
think Jaime is going to be the one to do
it
I made a prediction video about Theon
Greyjoy and his character arc a few
months back and in that prediction video
I said fian may end up killing Euron
while he is in the process of his
Redemption we have seen enough evidence
to know that urines going to capture
your alive during the attack at sea and
he's going to take your to Cersei as a
gift for this new alliance and I think
Theon may try to save Yara just like
Yara tried to say Theon when he was
Ramsay's prisoner
I think if Theon ends up attempting to
save his sister I think he could kill
your own in the process most people
wouldn't think Theon would have the
courage to do something like this right
now but I think that's why it makes the
most sense to happen but if Theon isn't
the one to kill you're on then I can see
Jaime killing him before he does
something too crazy there is already
plenty of evidence in the books that
proves you're on is actually going to be
the valonqar
so if you're on kill Cersei or tries to
kill Cersei Jaime will definitely take
his ass out next Cersei and Jaime may
not have the best relationship right now
but if you're on attempted to kill
Cersei to take the Iron Throne for
himself there is no way Jaime is going
to allow this to happen without any
consequences now I know most people
think Tyrion or Jaime is going to be the
valonqar but if you look at all the book
evidence it points to Euron Greyjoy
being the valonqar the most gray area
made a video about this in her video
convinced me that you're on will kill
Cersei in the
and I must make that very clear in the
books you're on will be the one to kill
Cersei but in the television show it may
go down a different way but Jaime could
end up being the Kingslayer once again
when he takes out the new Mad King
you're on Greyjoy what do you think
you're on is going to do if he gets his
hands on some of that wildfire as crazy
as he is he could try to blow up King's
Landing just as easily as Cersei would I
wouldn't put anything past your own
Greyjoy now I know the television show
didn't give him a great introduction but
I would be prepared to see absolute
madness from your on this season I have
high hopes for him being the ultimate
villain during season seven we can see
over the years that Jaime has been
having this internal conflict with
himself he wants to do the right thing
but as long as he is with Cersei or in
love with Cersei he is always going to
be at war with himself but now that
Cersei is going mad and she's about to
team up with another psycho this just
might be the tipping point for Jaime
Cersei and Euron may try and blow up
King's Landing together and if that's
the case I can see Jaime killing both of
them but what do you all think who do
you think will be the one to kill your
own Greyjoy or do you think Euron's
going to survive the entire series let
me know what you think about this down
below
I still hope Theon kills him but if
fiona is unable to get close enough to
him to do it then I think Jaime will be
the one to take him out those two will
be in King's Landing together for sure
but let me know your thoughts on this
topic thanks for stopping by and
watching today's video I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
all of you who support this channel on
patreon that really means a lot to me I
love all of y'all and I'll see you down
below bye
[Music]
you
[Music]